I simply hope it ends as soon as it
possibly can you know Justin
it is an unspeakable tragedy
you know I think many of us certainly
Europeans never expect never expected
that we'd see a war like this in Europe
uh the worst since World War II uh and
it is it is was a war that could have
been avoided I was involved a little bit
in those discussions uh Putin had
concerns they could have been addressed
uh but he chose another path so all I
can say is uh you know I think we cannot
allow Putin's aggression to go uh
uncontrolled uh he has to be responded
to uh and I hope as you know I hope that
it ends as quickly as possible and I
hope that the Russian people stand up
and and understand how terrible this is
not only for them but for the whole
world there is a real Sense on the
British left
that that they are torn actually about
whether or not the war was provoked by
NATO but also they are torn about the
extent to which it is right to back
Ukraine in all of Ukraine's war aims do
you have that is there that sense of the
American left as well there is but I I I
think in this one really somebody who
was opposed
so many wars of the United States you
know you're looking at somebody who
voted against the military budget
uh on this one
Putin did not have to do what he chose
to do so all I can say is I hope it
certainly ends as soon as possible that
there's a negotiated settlement but I
think we cannot allow Putin to run uh
Russia over an independent country right
and that does mean supplying the weapons
that the ukrainians say they need yes
uh let's turn to other matters one of
the things that I found fascinating
about your book it reminded me of
how close you came to the nomination not
not only the most recent one but
actually potentially back in in 2016
when you were running principally
against Hillary Clinton is is that a
fair thing to say that you worked
when we started the campaign Justin we
were something like five percent in the
polls
and nobody took us very seriously
nobody thought that a candidate with my
politics would go very far
but we ended up winning state after
State and millions and millions of votes
uh and really through the political
establishment into a State of shock but
at the end of the day when you're taking
on the political establishment you're
taking on the economic establishment
you're taking on the media establishment
that's a tough thing to do so we we lost
in 2016 but what came out of that is an
unprecedented uh movement in modern
American history of bringing working
people and young people together to
think big not small so we lost the
election but I think it is widely
recognized that we won something
enormously important we help change
political Consciousness in America and
what working people have a right to
expect from their government you stood
again in 2020 why did you lose that time
well that time was kind of much clearer
it was a larger field that I think at
one point where the 18 or 20. too many
for one TV studio one stage that's right
that's why the debates in half uh we won
the popular vote in in the first
state that was Iowa uh we won a
landslide Victory
uh in Nevada which is the third state we
won a victory in New Hampshire so we won
the first three states
uh and that got the establishment very
nervous we lost in South Carolina and
then we have what we call Super Tuesday
which is when a whole lot of States come
together and we were favored to win many
of those States uh and we ended up
winning California and so forth uh but
what ended up happening is the
establishment said you know what we
better rally around one candidate not
split the vote that candidate was Joe
Biden uh and he won a number of states
uh on super Tuesday and combined that
with covet and the inability to get out
and campaign he won the Democratic
nomination you made your piece with Joe
Biden very much haven't you and you
supported him
I supported him strongly a for two
reasons number one it was absolutely
imperative to do everything we could to
defeat Donald Trump in his
pathological lying in his
authoritarianism uh and number two at
the end of our campaign Biden did
something which was rather unusual for
an establishment Democrat he recognized
what our movement was about and he said
all right let's put together a task
force of his campaign and my campaign
let's look at issues like Health Care
the economy climate housing Etc so we
sat down with them and we hammered out a
very Progressive agenda wasn't
everything I wanted quite Progressive
though yes so when the Wall Street
journals say as they did recently Joe
Biden is Bernie Sanders they're kind of
right well I wouldn't go that one no Joe
Biden is not Bernie what's the
difference I mean if if Bernie Sanders
had won in in in 2020 what would the
difference be and won the presidency
what were the difference would have been
is I would have been I think a much more
activist
president in going on around the country
and demanding and understanding there
are limits to what a president can do
unless you have mass Grassroots working
class support
so what I would have done as president
has not only been Commander in Chief of
the military but organizer in Chief if
you like bringing working people
together to fight for an economy and a
government that worked for all uh as the
book talks about what we are looking at
right now is the movement in America and
I suspect in many other countries taught
an oligarchic form of society
all right so what we need to do is Rally
people black and white and Latino Asian
American our people to stand together
for a progressive Vision which
substantially improves lives the lives
of Working Families is part of that
Vision an attack on the people who run
the tech industry and their power that
we haven't properly seen on others
either side of the Atlantic yes the
answer the short answer is yes there's
obviously but a revolution in technology
in social media and so forth uh and one
of the things just that I worry about
very much when we touch upon it a little
bit in the book
is I think people are underestimating
the impact that artificial intelligence
and Robotics uh and the explosion of
technology that we're seeing is going to
have on the workforce so one of the
questions that has to be asked
who's going to benefit from that
explosion of technology is technology a
bad thing no it's not a bad thing if you
can produce twice as much with new
technology
I think that's good but you should
benefit as a worker from that not just
have the CEO of the large corporation
benefiting while you're thrown out on
the street and replaced by a robotic so
that is an issue we need a lot of
discussion about but it comes down to
the fundamental issue of this book and
that is power who has the power and I
think in this country certainly in my
country you're looking at a handful of
billionaires who have enormous control
over our economy we have more
concentration of ownership than we've
ever seen in American history you're
talking about more income and wealth
inequality than we've ever seen in
American history and in America I don't
know how many people in the UK are
familiar with our campaign Finance
system but basically billionaires are
able to buy elections so what you're
seeing is more and more power in the
hands of a few and I think a lot of
hopelessness uh and despair in in on the
part of of the many those things
particularly campaign campaign Finance
being sufficiently challenged by the
Biden Administration can they be
challenged by one one single
Administration
we could do a lot more I mean you know
without again going into all the details
we have a supreme court the reactionary
Supreme Court that made a decision on
what they call Citizens United which
essentially said that
billionaires have the freedom of speech
to buy elections that's their their
right their freedom uh I I don't agree
with that Biden doesn't agree with that
but we have got to be aggressive at the
state and local level to revitalize
democracy and make it clear that
billionaires should not be allowed to
buy elections that democracy means one
person one vote and that means not only
overturning
the citizens united Supreme Court
decision and we've tried to do some of
that in the Senate it also means turning
to Public Funding of Elections how
radical would you be so there's a great
feeling on the American left isn't the
the Supreme Court itself is is
illegitimate that this supreme court
because of the way it's elected and and
the the fact of the of the way that the
Senate is is set up
um would you be a court Packer or would
you threaten to go down that road in
other words to a point more justices
until you had a supreme court
the problem with packing the quarters
Roosevelt found out in the 30s is
so you pack it and the next guy comes
along he packs it ends up with 89 people
on the Supreme Court you know uh there
are ways to deal with it and I think
that has to do with that ways that are
constitutional uh which allow members to
rotate off of the Supreme Court so I
wouldn't be for packing the court but it
is an issue that has to be dealt with I
think one has to be very very naive not
to believe that the Supreme Court has a
political agenda and in this case today
it is a very reactionary political
agenda